is that a true enough Story the answer
is yes and no depends on the guy I don't
believe and I want to clarify I do not
believe every man should get married if
I'm 18 years old I'm with my high school
sweetheart we're broke we're living in
freaking West Virginia should we get
married heck no of course not you have a
99.9 divorce rate it is the dumbest
thing on planet Earth so what I like to
do we're actually working on on this
process I'm glad that you asked me we're
working on like this
um marriage evaluator where we take all
these different variables in the
individual and see what is the projected
divorce rate right we still have we're
still fixing it we're still playing
around with it so if a man needs certain
criteria right so if a man knows his
purpose he's financially sound he's
physically fit he's emotionally healthy
he's spiritually grounded and he meets
certain criteria and he wants to bring
in the right woman because it's not just
so much you being the right man she also
has to be the right woman right and then
then obviously you you gotta have the
conversation with the marriage mediator
if you want to do the prenups and things
along those lines if you're willing to
do all those things go through the
pre-engagement counseling and all that
stuff I support it I actually have I'm
not I think the straw man to my argument
is every man should get married no
matter what age and social no no it's a
very specific man that we that I believe
should get married and I believe every
man should work to become that man and
once he's that man I believe marriage is
in his best interest yeah that's
basically what I was saying about supply
and demand become a guy who's in high
demand and there'll be a ton of Supply
out there so so you think if a guy does
all those things he should get married
would you say legally to
um it's up to him to decide so for me I
have I have guys who are Christians I
have guys who are Muslims I have guys
who are atheist Buddhists so me I'm
never going to tell you how you choose
to get married because I the reason why
I obviously you don't advise on that um
because that's a religious conversation
because I'm a Christian but remember
like the majority of the world I mean
like what percent of America's
Christians like an actually majority a
majority of Americans practices that's
different okay even though people let me
give you examples
that was nice
teamwork if a guy gets to a certain
percentage like do you advise him you do
advise him to get legally married so
when it comes to the legalities not
legally yes or no oh no and yes it
depends on the person because it depends
on the person if somebody is you advise
yes if they're religious and then
otherwise so in regards to them choosing
about marriage it depends upon the
person I have Muslim people who they say
my name is Hafiz Hafiz means one
memorizes the Quran I am the only
Christian in the entire Bible lineage
and who's a male most my family are
Muslim so a lot of my Muslim family they
get they get married in um in Islam they
don't get married via the state I'm not
going to say no you should follow my
Christian or do this and get married to
this day you're free to do whatever you
want because in Islam you believe what
you believe and so to me that's why I
said depending on the religion depending
on the background I give different
advice for different people but that's
why one of the things I want to ask one
last thing people don't realize I've
stopped doing videos I've stopped doing
content in 2022 literally in 2021 I did
81 individual videos in 2022 I did five
why I've stopped and doing content right
now all we do is we have these
conversations with real life men we get
to know them we hear their stories we
hear their struggles we give them tools
and resources and we give specific
advice the biggest problem with Internet
what I can agree with you Pearl if you
believe this or not is the internet
gives you vague advice so some advice
can work for some man but doesn't mean
it works for other men you want to give
as specific as Vice as Vice as possible
and therefore you must know that man as
best as possible so recently based upon
how I know that man will be based on how
I would give him the advice okay I was
just curious your thought process like
so Christian does all the things you say
yes or no recommend legal legal not not
ceremony Christian yes legally okay so
if he's Christian yes fits in that
category high value man whatever you
think legally he should get married yes
and protect himself okay okay protect
himself how yeah so do it with a prenup
yeah so this is a myriad of ways of
protecting yourself so Natalie if you
don't mind can you go ahead and go back
to the data real quick
um
so um
go ahead and scroll down down
a little bit further oh you're just at
the bottom can you scroll up Alex scroll
the way down Pearl
um
scroll up the bottom one um number six
marriage mediation agreements
um great so that's a great article for
you guys to read to learn a little bit
more about mayor's mediation from a
lawyer's perspective so this is
something that I think guys need to do
so what happens is before you get
married you find that you get a marriage
mediator and I and depending on the
state's different laws and what you
would do is she'll sit you down and walk
through every detail of marriage how
much money you were you planning on
making
um what what um responsibilities each
person is going to have and then through
the mediation then the mediator will
work with the lawyer to coin the prenup
but this is very important because it
identifies what you expect out of that
marriage so these are additional ways a
man can protect himself by making sure
that if you're marrying a woman you guys
you and her are crystal clear you know
in regards to what you expect and then
if you want to go ahead and go through
the the do the premarital agreement aka
the prenup there's other things you can
do as well as well as if you want to
protect yourself from alimony there's
things that you do as well all these
resources we give to our guys in the
community we're constantly giving all
these two tools all this information for
them to win the most in life did
no I didn't oh why
in my personal because you'd recommend
the guy to get the prenup everyone is
different okay I'm not going to force
anybody to do it some people believe it
some people don't I personally I
personally me personally this is how
thesis persons is not Gods this is not
my best advice for men today I
personally believe for my wife the 50 50
makes sense for my wife it makes sense
to me so would you be willing to say
that you're the exception 100 okay and I
and I can say I would never I would
never advise anyone to do what I'm doing
this is my personal convictions
what if it ended up that you would it
was less than 50 50. like money let me
tell you the secret person so I'm just
going to say say and I I don't wish this
on you so don't you know but in 10 years
right and it's not 50 50. she takes 70
80 let's do 99. okay let's go freaking
99. let's say she takes 99 of the money
know what I have Adam
this what's really interesting is I
would I would advise people to look up
top
um divorce the the divorce the top
divorce payouts in U.S history and see
the guys who had a top divorce payouts
you know what happened to almost every
single last one of those guys Adam they
became even richer after their divorces
you know why because you can take away
their money you can never take away the
man's mind you can take away Tiger Woods
Money oh never mind they did take his
mind to it but Michael Jordan you can't
take away his mind
um the the what's the dude's um the
Amazon do Jeff Bezos so what happens is
to me the mind of the man you will
always be successful that's me
personally guys don't don't apply this
to your life so I personally believe me
personally I'm not I'm not a big money
guy I'm a very simplistic guy like you
you know if my if my family's taking
care of every everything is good you can
you can give me let me hit Ground Zero
take all my YouTube subscribers take all
my YouTube followers heck give her the
freaking house give her everything guess
what's gonna happen in three years I'm
gonna be right back that's the kind of
mindset I have I gotta I gotta give you
some pushback
I'm sure the chat's going wild over here
yeah
um and I'm glad before I even give you
the pushback I'm glad that you're saying
this is me I'm not advising this for you
because I think no man should do this so
for me yeah like I am not hypocritical
isn't that hypocritical no because
everybody's different now you're
interrupting me I'm sorry I'm sorry I
did it I'm sorry I'm sorry oh God okay
I'll mess with you but so for me like I
have friends that are going through a
divorce right now uh one really really
uh close friend and I know what he's
built okay and he's given the wife half
the house
um and rightfully so they raise the
family in the house 50 50 cool they're
split in the house it's worth a handful
of million dollars it's a Miami great
awesome but now she's getting 50 of his
business this guy is a successful
business this woman she she didn't do
[ __ ] yeah to help with the business okay
and for me that is a very very tough
thing let me go deeper bro please please
let's say that I'm worth 10 million
dollars okay and my wife like you gave
the 99 number by the way I
mean that's why I'm giving you the
pushback yeah yeah
and I want you to to think about this if
I'm worth 10 million dollars and we get
a divorce and I'm left with a hundred
grand and my wife gets 9.9 million
dollars it's ridiculous that's where as
a dude is gonna go jump off a [ __ ]
Bridge 100 and I want to clarify and I
want to clarify yeah I was extreme it
was extreme number the point that I made
is that when it comes to the the
prenuptial agreement everybody's
prenuptial agreement is different
whatever you feel comfortable with
that's what you should have so my point
is that if some men feel comfortable
with 50 50 some men say hey if we get
divorced you get this stipend you get
whatever you want to come up with me
personally this is my opinion I'm not
saying it's fact I'm saying this is my
personal opinion people are going to use
this to go against me it is how I feel
that's just what I I think the 50 50
from for my wife for my particular wife
I believe it makes sense I'll say one
thing and then I'm going to turn it over
to our friend Pearl yeah
huffies you've been making content about
men's self-improvement for how long
um
writing or video Everything uh probably
for 13 years so meaning when you got
married you knew exactly what you were
doing 100 you weren't like well it's
just science that's it you very you were
very intentional you said I'm doing this
for a reason yeah I've I'm very
clear-eyed and and open-hearted as to I
I am confident in my situation and I
know that most men shouldn't do this but
here's what I'm willing to do because
I'm very aware of what I'm doing as far
as getting married prenup I'm like
meeting like you didn't get like
Bamboozled at all no no and that's why
I'm okay with your decision because you
actively consciously logically made that
decision and nobody out there whether
you agree with the fees or [ __ ]
disagree with her fees
like you know what you're you're gonna
get bamboozled that's my point yeah and
that's why if that's your decision
that's your decision and one and one of
the things I also want to talk about in
regards to because when people talk
about marriage and the state what people
don't realize is that when it comes to
marriage and the state the state has
almost always been a marriage one of the
common misnomers is that the state was
never in marriage and all of a sudden in
the western marriages they all of a
sudden went into marriage if you go back
to one of the oldest ancient laws which
is Hammurabi's Codes there is literally
codes and rules literally Rules by
ancient Mesopotamia where there's where
there's rules that if a wife leaves a
husband she got nothing which I think is
a great Rule and pearl would love that
rule and if a husband left his wife with
children he must provide a sustainable
living so I know people are going to
straw man my argument Youth and use this
point to make their Clips every man
should do what he believes is best if
you want to give your wife zero give her
zero if you want to give her half give
her half whatever you feel is best as a
man that's what I advise you I'm just
sharing my opinion we did an episode
yesterday and and I want to give you the
takeaway that I thought whether you
agree with this person disagree with
this person I'm just letting you know
what I took away from TLA what he said
yesterday he said before you get married
spend 500 or a thousand bucks and meet
with an attorney and just understand
what you're getting yourself into 100
knowledge is power that's great advice
step two
I'm advising you this is him get a
prenup yeah whatever the prenup says you
figure out step three do a personality
test that's great as to make sure that
the person that you're marrying you guys
are in the same wavelength I think again
I'm not a lawyer this is not my personal
advice I'm recording this but I think
that is very applicable advice for today
the lovely Pearl go ahead your response
well prenups can be thrown out too and
I'm so I think that's something that men
should be aware of as well so do you
know why to get thrown out Pearl I mean
a different
there's one
they're not like too close to the
marriage basically they um they'll say
she was under duress of course basically
so you can't like throw your throw your
girl a prenup the day before there's
ways to do that there's ways to do it
right and there's ways to do it wrong I
love that and bro that's fantastic guys
listen to where Pearl said because
that's what we both can agree on it's
very important that you educate yourself
on the prenup educate yourself because
each state is different as well as
educate yourself how it is thrown out
because like I said my biggest thing is
I I want to help men win in this
environment we know these laws that
educate yourself okay if we know that
prenups are throwing out these seven
different ways protect yourself in these
seven different ways however the problem
still is it's up to the judge and judges
differ and you can't really predict what
judge you're gonna get so which goes
back to what I was saying I I just I
understand why men just avoid this chaos
my question to you Pearl is how many
percent of prenups is on the right way
or thrown away
how much what percent yeah I don't
actually know exactly so the fundamental
reason you don't know
okay come here thank you
um no it's it's not that every woman
will it's that every woman can
and that's that's the point A lot of
times they're like that they're talking
about it's like that's a lot of power to
give someone because it goes back to
you're signing a contract where the
other person has benefited to leave you
could do this you could put the prenup
in and help avoid a situation and maybe
most of the time it will but the whole
point is they're looking for a reason to
throw it out and there's even lawyers
that have come forward and say I don't
believe prenups work final thoughts
my point is this when we're giving
people we have to give them practical
advice no no you do on your channel you
do on your channel go ahead I'm sorry
again we're not giving advice we're not
giving advice you give advice sorry
that's a fair statement because she's
not an advice Channel she's an
entertainment I'm not talking about
Pearl is that okay with you yeah I'll
let you thank you so much bro so to me
one of the one of the biggest things in
regards to that statement is people can
do anything right don't get friends
because they can stab you in your back
because a friend stabs in your back
don't drive a car because you can get in
the crash don't anything can't happen my
desire is to help men alleviate the risk
that happen yes is there a percentage of
one percent chance you can throw your
prenup can be thrown away of course
there's always a risk I want to give men
the best odds possible to win in this
environment and so man if you look if
you're looking to get a prenup make sure
you go to your individual State
understand the specific laws for your
state understand what what cases in your
state do prenup was thrown about protect
yourself to be able to have the best
life possible that's my advice for men
to win the most prenups can be thrown
out if the judge sees something that
makes them deemed unfair and if we're
going to use the car analogy So Adam I
got a question for you oh she was
waiting for this one so okay if you were
driving your car right and you found out
that at the intersection
they're paid to hit you they're paid
they're given money to hit you at the
intersection would you understand if
guys may be like you know what I'm gonna
stop at this light and not go through
uh well full disclosure I haven't had a
car in 10 years
everywhere to avoid nonsense like this
but to address your actual question yeah
I'm not looking for drama I'm gonna
avoid that but I think that's like the
perspective but it's like why do all
this one there's a difference a man are
built to protect and provide that's the
purpose of man Patrick David we love
Patrick shout out Patrick I know you're
not watching this but I love you yeah
shout out Pastor David Patrick Davis
said what is that Jewish proverb every
man should do three things yeah write a
book plan a tree have a son yeah I
believe that men are living their
fullest potential when they're
protecting providing leading a family
yes anyone cannot drive the intersection
but are we telling men to never have
families never to live their their
potential never to experience
can I finish my conversation go ahead
thank you thank you thank you thank you
be able to have those things that
Patrick David advice go ahead Adam no
all good we we we're going to switch
topics here I think we've we've
exhausted the marriage and divorce
content of course we're going to have
short clips about marriage and divorce
for the next decade we're good I got
we're good let's move on to a couple of
things we were talking about the concept
of men leading women follow Natalia and
I kind of what your what your parents do
about like the the father your as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible